c'est clair
Hé
oh père oh
le grand
hey tu sais elle avait pitié quelle pitié ça montre
le dimanche droit
cette année nous sommes en mars un garçon
17 ans était coincé ici dans la rue et
une autre avec ses amies maria da silva et
joão vitor hugo burko janvier
est passé de t
Hé
50 cm de neige sur n'importe quel moteur car
J'ai joué dans la douleur
la musique de ruiz d'ailleurs s'arrête dans laquelle
personne n'arrête jamais un animal de 300 000 r
11 9 mm couleur 15 ans et josé bien sur
Je ne pense pas que je reste le même et
exécutez nani jusqu'à ce qu'il demande l'activation
absolu nécessaire grand signe ok
équitable
le football qu'il joue et il a dit
moi j'étais déjà loin avec soeur jessica
ruine du jeu dans le but et fabio josé